this feels weird I'm just recording i'm
not streaming but i'm about to play
nakamura who's currently streaming
struggling to find checkmates okay so
I'm putting knocketh stream on mute and
I'm playing a London system because
that's all I know how to play against
good players he's playing this line okay
9f three preventing me five I can't draw
arrows because something's weird
see five is a good line I think I'll
play d5 I'll have some like Bishop f4
Benoni
yeah p5 is good he knows what he's doing
okay I'll put the wait d5 was already a
issue though am i already losing upon
before I can't play like what do I do
here eat three there's I could play like
a high e3 if before it probably might be
one not pretty but
I do what I got to do if I knew he would
play this line I probably wouldn't play
London this is very annoying line but at
least he's thinking like B 491 if might
be six like there should be five Chuck
yeah I have to figure out how to
activate the arrows a six that's a good
sign
the problem is he's still threatening to
play Bishop d7 and win a pawn before
can't really be played maybe it Bishop
d3 or a for maybe a four looks wrong
though before oh this is so bad
it should be three what do I do should
take three I'm losing I he has before
but if before night e to Knight takes d5
I should be four so maybe it's okay now
I have e4 if I want okay now I actually
feel a little bit comfortable I used a
lot of time there but I'm not losing a
pawn I don't think I have Ricky one
coming
I mean he has before c4 whenever he
wants I have h3 at some point a solid
move I mean the queenside pressure could
be annoying is before coming so I have
to lose a pawn
unfortunately 92 doesn't help terrible
but before 92 okay so I'm I'm treating
this like a gambit where I lost upon but
he's committed to c4 I want to play f4
or even g4 let's start with chief or
maybe f3
maybe g5
I'll start with this this is very
unpleasant because the queenside pawns
are going to be very annoying Black has
a bishop hair like windy six let's win
odd the g5s hanging have to play h4 it's
such a terrible game
d5 let's take this player up t1 I'm
nervous I don't know why I'm nervous I'm
not supposed to be nervous while playing
the chess bishop g3 I guess not looking
good
I mean is there any hope it's play Queen
f3 such pawns I want to bring the knight
to e3 and then to g4 eventually let's
take this way
really so he just wants to Queen
takes chicks this is not good this is
really not good like what do I do I'm
just losing I resign I was so bad
rematch one more I feel so devastated